I want out of them sure and the great  white somewhere hello  we want this live-action retelling of  Beauty and the Beast more than we can  tell turn into the light Disney gave us  just enough to whet our appetite in this  Golden Globes TV spot featuring Emma  Watson singing as Belle she is the ones  you have fun I'm just a face to me I  want some check out the film's new  poster with it's a list cast including  Emma Thompson as mrs. potts Luke Evans  as Gaston Sir Ian McKellen as Cogsworth  and Josh GAD as Lefou there's a scope to  it and I paid those to it that having  seen it I can tell you was unexpectedly  very emotional and I just think that the  new music as well as the old music is  just it's gonna blow everybody away  [Music]